we saw how to create a principal
component analysis
of some gene expression data and here i
want to add some additional elements
so that we understand how to color the
individual objects in our
principal component analysis scatter
plot as well as add a legend
from the data itself and learn how to
modify the way that principal component
analysis is visualized
so that we get better separation between
groups of samples
so let's go ahead and start the first
thing we'll do is we'll
use a library called gg45
gg45 is useful for principal component
analysis and things like autoplot
which is a modification of how ggplot
works
specifically for this kind of data the
second thing we'll do is we'll
load our data so we'll call it
expressiontable
last time we took an expression table
and we transposed it
this time i've already prepared a
transpose table
the problem is that whenever you do the
transposition here
you lose one of the key items
in the table which is one of the column
names
and so saving that file correctly
separately is going to be very useful
so we'll use read table and
here i already have a link
for that file and put this link in the
comments
remember that we need to do sep which is
the separator
is the tab so it's a tab delimited file
header equals true
check names equals false
well actually here we don't need to do
that
so we'll do just header true and
row names equals 1.
now the next thing we want to do is we
want to create a data frame
and from the expression table if you
actually look at the expression table
you'll see that there are first two rows
that have the name of the sample
and the group id so let's view this
expression table
to do that here we'll do print and
expression table
that's right
so as you can see we have here the name
of our sample and we also have
a group name you can see here that
you've got some group names
and you've got the sample names and then
that's the group
okay so now
that we know what's in our data
we can go ahead and
run our pca so we'll create the
data frame and that will be just rows
2 to 16 so this will be
expression table
we already took the first row
as the names so we only have two
so that would be two to 16
and we can do pca
or sorry pca will be pr
comp and here we'll add
df
and now we can visualize it so auto plot
pca let's see what happens
okay so just like last time we see here
some of the samples but we don't know
which ones they are of course we can
label them
so if we just add label equals true
we'll see that whatever is stored in our
row names which are the sample names
it's going to be displayed
but it's not very useful because what we
want to do is we want to know
the color by group so let's delete this
and instead we'll say that we'll use the
data that we originally
loaded expression table
and we'll take from here one of the
columns that is called group
to label our data
sorry made a mistake right here
all right so as we can see now we have
our sample types colored by
different colors and the colors are
displayed right here in a nice legend
so if we look closely we see that this
is the luminal samples
and here we have the basal samples and
one of the luminol samples
is actually fairly close to these as
well as these are fairly close to
so the basal and the normal like it's
fairly close together
the result of this analysis could be
placed and the different samples could
be scaled
and the way we can do that is we can add
here
scale with a dot
equals true
let's take a look at it now now you can
see that there's a fairly good
separation between
all of our groups here we have the
luminal in the middle of the basal like
here are the normal-like and here we
have also the cloud and low
so they're now nicely separated we can
also center
it doesn't really change much but the
plot moved a little bit so everything
now
is more aligned to the center of this
chart so this
scatter plot now is centered around this
zero
zero position so what we get is a pretty
nice
uh chart that you can use directly in
your
reporting of whatever data you've
analyzed and
it's a very simple script
that literally has one two three four
five five lines
and importantly uh don't forget
that this color comes from
a column so this should be an actual
column name
in your source data of course as usual
remember to check out the full tutorial
on code.omicslogic.com
it's a new site where we are offering a
number of different tutorials
including in r and in python on how to
run
different types of statistical analysis
visualization
and machine learning algorithms on omics
data until next time